madame êtes vous pour ou contre la
nation et pourquoi bien sûr ce que je
trouve que pour une piqûre qui est très
facile à faire ça protège des maladies
qui sont peut-être dangereuse
énormément de maladie ont disparu
maintenant du globe en partie où elles
sont fortement atténuée parce qu'on
vaccine les enfants que tu faussaires je
suis pour la vaccination
et parce que j'estime que sa vie de
beaucoup de maladies eh bien je crois
qu'avec les progrès actuels il est
nécessaire de vacciner les enfants
malheureusement pour mon compte
personnel il y affronte angers perdu un
enfant qui a été vacciné au bcg qui je
pense à l'époque n'était pas au point
alors évidemment la question peut-être
controversé maintenant je crois que les
résultats sont peut-être des problèmes
maintenant dessus pour la voiture je
vais me faire vacciner bientôt sur les
normes dans quelle mesure dans quelle
mesure ça ne si vous voulez s'élimine un
risque sur le moment et pour les enfants
ne sait pas exactement ce que ça donne
après comme sûrs j'avais pour les
vaccinations le retour parce que je
trouve que tu étais en particulier pour
la poliomyélite pense que tant les
enfants attrapent de maladie et le set
handicapé dans toute leur vie je suis
pour aussi sa limite évidemment les
épidémies et ça permet d'avoir des
enfants certainement à l'abri de tout ce
maladie très dangereuse
maintenant je suis pas tellement pour le
bcg le vcg martin n'a pas été vaccinés
puis elle a fait une primo infection
alors maintenant toute la famille est
vaccinée loi y compris et même le petit
bébé parce que on ne restera plus les
épidémique nous avons au moyen-âge et
c'est un bien de de faire vacciner les
enfants je suis en général pour les
vaccinations mais je suis contre le bcg
a provoqué certains accidents chez des
enfants d'amis à moi je suis pour la
toutes les vaccinations
bcg que j'ai crime
fall et le faire avec une grande
surveillance et non pas n'importe
n'importe quand et n'importe quel mot
mort sur tout âge et tout à fait contre
parce que je trouve que ça fatigue les
enfants et on vaccine coup sur coup et
je trouve que
c'est pas bon je suis pour la
vaccination 15 estiment que depuis que
la vaccination est en progression il ya
moins de cas de maladies je suis
absolument pour parce que malgré tout ça
évite beaucoup de maladies beaucoup de
contagion enfin on est tout de même plus
tranquille
[Musique]